Black Widow's multi-layered and
you know,
motivated
and determined, and
all of those things. And,
she has an arc.
I would love to take
this character
in every different direction.
I'm always picking up
after you boys.
The possibilities are really
endless.
Before I worked for S.H.I.E.L.D.,
I made mistakes.
But I'm done running
from my past.
Very few actors can
say that they've worked on
a character for ten years.
And then, suddenly have
this chance to delve deep into
the inner workings of
this person.
We have to go back to
where it all started.
Here's one movie
people have been
asking us to make
for a very long time.
More so than any other film.
The Black Widow movie.
We're gonna be able
to create something that
is a different flavor
for the Marvel universe.
I'm just excited to see the
real Black Widow.
She's not a classic hero
because she has
a dark past.
What brings you home?
You get to see all these
facets of her that we've
never ever seen before.
We have unfinished business.
One thing's for sure.
It's gonna be a
hell of a reunion.
Marvel Studios'
Black Widow
in theaters May 1st.